Stranger Things returns
in 2022
and, thanks to a series of
cryptic location teasers,
we're as hungry for answers
as Eleven is for Eggos.
What better way to
fill the time
before season four arrives
than to go and round up some
of the wildest fan theories
about where Stranger Things
could go?
To be clear,
we're confirming nothing.
These are just fan theories.
So let's jump in.
Our big question at
the end of season three was:
Is Hopper really dead?
In the emotional finale,
we saw Joyce Byers
destroying the gates
to the Upside Down,
evaporating every Russian
in the room
and we're led to believe
Hopper along with them.
We ended the season mourning
our beloved police chief
only for the action
to cut to
a Russian outpost
in Kamchatka
where two guards decide
not to feed
the American to
their Demogorgon.
Fans suspected
this might refer to Hopper,
and that seems to be
confirmed by
the Russian location teaser
showing
a shaved David Harbour
working in
a snowy prison camp.
So this confirms that Hopper
is alive and well, right?
Some fans think
it might be a fake out
or, at least,
not as simple as it seems.
One theory is that,
while Hopper is alive,
he's actually trapped
in the past in 1959:
a year that's very important
to season four,
as we'll discuss later.
The main thinking behind
this take
is that the Russians in
Kamchatka have a Demogorgon.
The logic goes that
if there is only one of
these monsters
and that one was destroyed
at the end of season one,
then this scene
would have to be in the past
to make sense.
It would also gel with
the nod to
Back to the Future
in season three.
That's another story
about people from the 1980s
getting thrown back
to the 1950s.
It's not the only time
travel theory in this video,
so do hold on to
that thought.
Another theory is that
Hopper is alive in Russia
in 1986,
but the American
the guards refer to is
actually Martin Brenner,
the ice cold director of
Hawkins National Laboratory
last seen getting munched on
at the end of season one.
It would make sense that
Russians obsessed with
accessing the Upside Down
would maybe work with
the scientist who discovered
the gate in the first place.
The theory also argues that,
if Hopper is
the special prisoner
mentioned
at the end of season three,
why is he left doing hard
labour on a railway line
in the Russian
location teaser?
I don't know!
I've never done this before!
The Brenner idea ties into
another batch of
fan theories
that Brenner definitely has
a role to play
in season four.
The lab teaser
for season four
takes us back to
the Rainbow Room,
where young Eleven
and the other test subjects
at
Hawkins National Laboratory
were experimented on
by Mathew Modine's
creepy researcher.
This scene could just be
a flashback
to Eleven's
original captivity,
but some fans wonder
if it might be proof
that Brenner survived
his Demogorgon encounter
and is setting up
a second lab
to raise a fresh batch
of psychic warriors.
The fact that one of the
episode titles is "Papa",
the name Eleven called
Brenner in the past,
certainly backs
that idea up.
Yes, Papa.
Other fans point to
the clock in the teaser
and throughout all the
season four teasers
as being another hint of
time travel,
that instead of this being
a flashback,
Eleven somehow ends up
travelling back to
the Rainbow Room
to meet her former nemesis.
Another really wild idea
suggests that
Brenner will return,
but that he'll be
the Mind Flayer in disguise.
I mean, hey,
look at the damage it did
by possessing Billy,
a simple
swimming pool attendant!
A body with Brenner's
access would be
a juicier target.
Go to hell,
you piece of shit!
Oh! And another
Rainbow Room side note.
One theory believes that
season four will introduce
more of
Eleven's fellow
child test subjects.
We've already met
Eight, aka Kali,
in season two
and had a taste of
her distinct powers.
I can make people see, or
not see, whatever I choose.
And the supporting
Stranger Things comic books
feature other numbered
children, like Six and Nine.
With the lab teaser showing
multiple children,
could we finally see
Eleven go full X-Men
with
her fellow test subjects?
Time will tell.
Yoohoo!
One thing's obvious from
the location teasers,
and that is that Stranger
Things is hitting the road
in season four
with the California
and Russia snapshots
hinting at a global scale.
Fan theories are trying to
make sense of it all,
working out how characters
in different locations
could interact.
One theory wonders
if Joyce will go hunting
for Hopper in Russia
after receiving
a Russian doll in the post,
suggesting that
she could team up with
conspiracist Murray
on the Soviet trip.
That may also explain
the mysterious Russian dolls
some fans of the show
received in the post.
Even trickier is linking
the lab teaser
to the other events.
One viewer suggests
a link exists
between Hopper and Brenner's
old lab
that maybe
his daughter Sarah
once had something to do
with the Rainbow Room.
There's a very old
fan theory that
this scene of Hopper crying
over his daughter
in season one
is actually set inside
Hawkins Lab, for example.
Another fan spotted that
the tag line for the season
"We're not
in Hawkins anymore"
has connections to
the Wizard of Oz's
"We're not
in Kansas anymore",
where Dorothy famously went
over the rainbow.
Rainbow. Rainbow Room.
Does this imply
the test chamber scene
in the lab tease
isn't in Hawkins?
Might that tie it to
Russia or California?
We're truly down
the rabbit hole now.
No! Wait, that's
a different kids' story.
And, as for the spooky
mansion in the Creel teaser,
one eagle-eyed,
no, -eared viewer
reminds us the ticking
of a clock was heard
when El ventured into the
Upside Down in season one,
which this theorist thinks
ties the events
in the Creel House
to anywhere
the Upside Down reaches.
More clock theories
in a second.
Let's stick with El
for a moment.
The California teaser shows
her yearning for home
by building a cute model
of Hopper's cabin,
but she might have
bigger problems
than feeling homesick.
One question fans
definitely want answered
in season four is whether
El will get her powers back.
At the end of season three,
her tie with
the supernatural
was seemingly severed
after fighting
the physical form
of the Mind Flayer.
Although there is
one fun theory that
perhaps it was Hopper
who suppressed her powers
deliberately
to dissuade her from
entering the dangerous
Russian base under the mall
and to prevent her from
using her powers
to track him to Russia.
Quite why he'd do this
is fuzzy
and the idea that
he put something
in El's fizzy drink
to stop her powers
is the kind of
mad conspiracy
you'd expect
from Murray Bauman.
You do not get to
question me.
However she lost them,
fans agree that El's
abilities will reawaken
in season four.
Theorists think the shots
of El freaking out
in the Rink-O-Mania have
big Carrie energy.
We also see her being
picked on by smug students
in her new
Californian school,
so she's likely
ready to snap.
Could a lack
of roller skating prowess
unclog
her super power blockage?
Bully Eleven
and the only thing you're
skating on is thin ice.
-My arm!
-Go.
Or could it be
a more emotional betrayal
that kickstarts
her cerebral capabilities?
With El leaving Hawkins
at the end of season three
to travel with the Byers to
their new Californian home,
a few worried fans wonder if
her long-distance
relationship
with Mike won't work.
Yes, it feels like
we're jinxing them
just by entertaining
the thought,
but some viewers think Mike
might find a new girlfriend.
We know things got rocky
in places in season three
and El's new bestie, Max,
encouraged her to be
more independent
in matters of love,
but we're not sure we could
handle any more heartbreak,
so we're going to pretend
we haven't heard that one.
I love you, too.
Another intriguing thread
to season four is
the importance
of the Creel family
introduced in the
Creel teaser for the show.
According
to newspaper images
released on social media,
the family were involved
in a terrible crime in 1959,
explaining why some believe
Hopper may have travelled to
that year in particular.
What we do know is that,
27 years later,
we see our Hawkins regulars
breaking in to
the Creels' now abandoned
home, but, from here,
the fan theories break
in multiple directions.
One attentive fan thinks
there's physical
similarities between
Mrs. Creel
and Karen, Wheeler,
maybe suggesting
a family tie
that the gang
might investigate.
Others hypothesise that the
casting of Robert Englund
as Victor Creel,
aka Freddy Krueger from
A Nightmare on Elm Street,
might be a nod to
Nancy Wheeler's importance,
as some fans note
the similarities between her
and Nancy Thompson,
the heroine in Elm Street.
It would be meta as hell,
but Stranger Things doesn't
shy away from references.
A more common theory is that
the creepy grandfather clock
featured prominently
in the teaser is
a gateway to
the Upside Down,
much like the one
Nancy discovered in the tree
in season one.
Did a connection with
the twisted mirror dimension
exist before Eleven opened
a gate in 1983
and did it cast some
dark magic on the Creels?
Or maybe the clock is just
another hint towards
the time travel shenanigans
that pop up in loads of
these theories.
Personally, we don't mind
the outcome as long as
we get more Sherlock Holmes
quotes from Dustin.
The world is full of
obvious things
which nobody by any chance
ever observes.
Of course, these are just
a sliver of the theories
surrounding season four
of Stranger Things.
We've read hundreds of
out-there ideas
from the fans,
from the idea that
the Upside Down is
a potential future Earth
that Eleven has to
prevent from happening
to one Reddit user who hopes
Bob will come back from
the dead at some point,
keeping the Bob dream alive.
You've got to love it.
I hope it doesn't suck.
Of course, we won't know
if any of this is true
until part one of
Stranger Things season four
arrives on May 27.
And a huge part of
the fun is speculating
and digging through old
episodes for inspiration.
Why not share
your wildest theories
in the comments below?
We promise not to rub them
in your face
when part one lands in May.
And make sure to subscribe
to Still Watching Netflix
for more features about your
favourite films and shows.